[Music]
good morning today
is an awesome day because uh my parents
are finally in town
to meet luca since luke has been born um
lucas just hasn't seen a whole lot of
people like the only people lucas met
has been uh tis family her mom and like
you know a few cousins and stuff like
that but luca has not met any of our
friends
and uh and you know my parents haven't
had a chance to fly in and meet luke yet
either so luca meets his grandparents
today for the first time
and uh me and my brother stayed up late
last night talking so i didn't go to
sleep till late and then luca woke up as
soon as i tried going to sleep and so i
think i only have like about two hours
of sleep so i'm running on empty gonna
go pick up my parents right now cause
i've been timing it out like i want i
want my parents to meet luka when like
lucas is the happiest and like we said
in previous vlogs luke is like the
smiliest and like uh just like the best
his best self whenever like he just
wakes up and so i'm like been trying to
gauge when luke is going to wake up and
then uh picking up my parents right now
and my brother and his fiancee are
staying with us um parents are at a
hotel so i'm gonna go pick them up right
now and finally get this family reunion
going so yeah here we go
so joe's enemy good morning perfect yeah
it actually means uh
early rise event
sunday morning
sun oh it's the early morning
literally early morning oh okay
uh tiff would say uh buenos dias yeah
every every morning yeah so we're trying
to uh be trilingual right now
but you'll get it like
you know a little bit yeah well he used
to
the spanish and chinese yeah
yeah he can distinguish oh this is
spanish oh this is english oh this is
chinese you know that's true all right
or you'll just end up going to school
and thinking every language is the same
thing
like me in hong kong
i was at school or at a daycare and then
i was i think because ninja turtles was
uh really popular and i was trying to
explain
i was trying to explain like oh ninja
turtles live in the sewers or something
but i didn't know the english were for
sewers so i kept saying hank hancock
yeah and then no one knew what i was
saying but i was trying to say you were
sad i think and i was angry yeah
don't you understand
really you you're talking to your friend
with the word
yeah
yeah
they didn't understand and then i was
the one that was angry you guys ready to
meet luka yeah
yeah are you ready let's go the moment
you've been waiting for
[Music]
that
it is
[Music]
luca
my grandson
oh my goodness hi
look at you look at you i was so nervous
leading up to the moment for them to
meet luca like i don't know i just
wanted luca to be like as most
presentable as possible and like for
them to get to meet their first blood
grandchild it's a huge moment so knowing
how special that moment is and having
that first blood grandchild be my child
too it just i don't know just felt
really special hi how are you doing this
morning
you want grandpa to hold you no yeah
yeah hold here
okay oh my goodness
tiny
you're tiny to be able to share your own
child to your parent and see the
generations come together i think it's a
very beautiful
moment do you know us huh i'm sorry oh
you smell good
you're funny
he kept scaring me yeah you're so so
so good
baby
oh my god in the flesh he's like this is
too much so many strangers
[Music]
you guys
you guys enjoy first
i i need to do the holding like on the
couch you know that's exactly the thing
teddy bear yeah this is easy now see
he's holding up his head it's also
really special to see luca with casey's
dad in particular because i don't have
my dad anymore in my life and my grandpa
also just passed
well my mom's dad i never knew my dad's
dad so yeah just like you know older
male figures in my son's lives
really casey's dad is the only
one in both of my kids lives so just
seeing him interact with his grandpa is
super special especially knowing that
he'll never
get to have any moments with my dad at
least isaac was able to get
to have and capture moments with my dad
but luca will never
get that unfortunately but at least
he'll get that with you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey
that's so rad i still appreciate his
head
that's so proud
cute seeing him happy and getting to
meet his family
and i'm like are you excited to meet
your family you're just like
so cute
how is it going baby boy
hi hey keep myself oh yeah i do remember
one time he just tooted that was so cute
this is the closest
baby thing ever to me
you're the closest baby you're a baby
thing luca
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's like this is my gift to you
i got the red pocket for you
here
so
are you going grab you're going to
how do you say it so you're going to be
growing up
there you go
okay what i said is
uh grow faster
and taller healthy and taller and
healthy and being healthy
[Music]
oh he got it
the mama is hard to say because
yeah the tone i can't do it i can't do
it like i try but i don't know if i'm
nailing it
um but anyway grandma and grandpa mama
mama
there we go you really gotta drop it
down mama yeah
wait for real sounds like i'm making fun
of it so i'm like talking like this and
i go hey mama
yeah what it's very sing-songy for sure
the difference between my momma is
i mean it's like it's literally like an
octave lower from each other and to me i
hear just
mama it's like
yeah just they both sound like mother
anyway i lost what i was trying to say
how does it feel to
be holding your grandson
i feel
i'm mature now
sure yeah
i finally grew up yeah i grew up yeah
i'm not sure i have a grandson i was
still a kid myself
this is the kid
the new kid in town is here i wish i
could see him getting married one day
yeah that's your goal now yes my goal
yeah you have to have a goal for you'll
be 90 years old
[Music]
when it comes to my mom meeting luca so
my mom was actually in the hospital the
day
he was born but
due to covet uh restrictions she wasn't
able to come in and see the baby like no
one could visit us in the hospital but
she was in the waiting room and so she
was there the day he was born but didn't
get to meet him then she came over a few
days later to drop off some clothes that
my aunt and my cousin
gifted luca but that time i didn't
document it because it didn't really
count because my mom didn't even hold
luca at that time she just kind of
peeked at the newborn baby i was like
okay i gotta go
and you know like that was it was really
quick hey baby but then when she finally
held luca for the first time that was on
march 19th and it was so cute like just
seeing luca
in her arms and immediately
like i had like a flashback moment to
when she met isaac for the first time
it's like she's holding isaac all over
again it's so crazy i love you you know
this is the very first time he's being
held by anyone other than me
casey or isaac
that's true but the best part though was
a month later on april 20th was the
second time that she met luca and held
him see
[Music]
that was so sweet because he was just
cracking up he was laughing so hard she
was making him laugh so hard
[Laughter]
and just seeing that interaction just
really like it melted my heart i'm like
oh my god that's so sweet
[Music]
i don't know just seeing our parents
interact with him and
hello baby seeing them interact with him
it just really like touches my heart i
don't know because it's like you know
it's our parents we came from them and
he came from us and
i don't just seeing the different
generations it's just it's just so wild
it's time to eat
it's feeding time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you